investigators Tonight video appears to
show two murder suspects running through
a strip Hotel those women reportedly
meeting their victim just minutes before
they allegedly shot and killed him in a
guest room now evidence the news now
investigators obtained show how police
pieced this case together
video the 8 news now investigators
obtained shows 25 year old Brian
altamarano Solano walking hand in hand
with Erica Covington and Ariana Taylor
both 20 minutes before the women are
accused of killing him it's 2 35 a.m on
Monday May 15th police say a camera
inside a Caesar's Palace hallway
captures the trio walking to altamarano
solano's room prosecutors noting the bag
slung over his chest 14 minutes later
that same camera catches Covington and
Taylor running away police say one of
them has their victim's bag on her as
she drops her phone detectives getting
more surveillance video this one from a
different strip property they say one of
the women is wearing the bag as she
charges her phone
prosecutors say Covington and Taylor are
the duo in these Instagram videos shown
to a grand jury where they're wearing
the same or similar outfits as the
morning of the murder more photos show
the hotel room door where police say
just 15 minutes transpired before the
women allegedly shot and killed
altamarano Solano inside officers say
they found a cartridge casing matching
Taylor's gun altamarano Solano had
stayed in the room with a different
woman who told investigators he didn't
speak English and was in the U.S from
Nicaragua seeking Asylum other evidence
in the case includes two explicit videos
of the women and altamarano Solano
inside the room recorded at 2 44 and 2
45 minutes later the women are seen
running down that hallway it wouldn't be
until 11 that morning more than eight
hours later a worker found Alta Morano
Solano dead on the floor from a gunshot
now both women have pleaded not guilty
and they're due in court again Thursday
the 8 News investigators reached out to
a friend named in court documents and
she asked for privacy at this time